belle tutti ragazzi bevere di avessero
video sono pochi geni siano tornati su
the sims guardatemi massimo che vi devo
di una cosa abbastanza importante no
questo non c'entra niente queste ma è
forte ed supportate mi su for nancy lo
lascio lo lascio ho fatto quattro
episodi di the sims con sabrina infatti
perché volevo ritornare a giocare un
pochettino the scenes perché non mi
ricordavo come si faceva e quindi
invitato sabrina ho fatto la famiglia
con selena insomma ho usato i trucchi
per farmi i soldi aveva in realtà io
volevo fare giocare a the sims e
seriamente quindi fa trovandomi il
lavoro trovando mina ragazza non
mettendo me l'ha già in casa che è
troppo easy e quanto vorrei che funziona
sostituti nella realtà quindi ho fatto
quella roba con sabrina per per giocare
un po così a caso per divertirmi per via
dei semplici vorrei giocare per la prima
volta per la prima volta voglio giocarci
seriamente voglio farmi la mia famiglia
la mia casa passa mi faccio un microbus
di soldi all'inizio giusto per
cominciare ma cominciamo possa andare
ragazzi al bunga lo del ruscello alban
gallaro del ruscello che non è la casa
più grande del mondo ma è una casa
comunque ottima direi quindi possiamo
andare direttamente lì ho un fondo
pensionistico di 200.000 simoleon let's
go la casa è bella mi piace non è la
miglior casa che esista sulle sims
ma è una casa già strafiga così quindi
che possiamo tenerla poi magari ci
trasferiamo in una più grande ma per
adesso va bene tanto dobbiamo iniziare a
vivere let's go amico mio
sei felice e una casa bella e felice
allora vediamo di fare le cose giuste
allora entriamo dentro i non so quali
sono i miei vicini di casa non so niente
altro c'è una pop on a dei fori ciao zia
vorrei parlare semplicemente con le
persone perché non conosco nessuno
ovviamente nel prossimo episodio metterò
anche some perché voglio vivere io con
il mio cane e basta c'è poi se conosco
qualcuna è tutto un altro discorso però
per adesso voglio parlare per vivere
come se fossi io cioè io che sopravviva
milano uguale stessa cosa guardi sul
tablet ma cosa giochi acquisita la vita
di videogiochi non ho fatto niente la
fattura solo l'ha fatto da solo non ho
fatto nulla
lui lo sapeva lo sapevi saggia farlo
youtuber perfetto allora amico mi ostuni
innanzitutto che non trova un lavoro
perché non è che quest'acqua fa niente
ha fame non lavori va quindi troviamo un
lavoro lavora perfetto registra mister
registra ministero del lavoro perfetto
vai corrie perfetto quale tutti tuo
personale youtuber senza l'iscrizione
per il lavoro faccio video diverto la
gente e faccio il fermo né ecco vi dico
solo non so ammette non metto sandra
ragazzine l'episodio solo perché ho
bisogno veramente di prenderci un attimo
dimestichezza col lavoro e tutto poi lo
metto tranquilli
la novità di ministerio renzulli
permetterà ingannare dando la scossa
alla mano a questo quartiere il paradiso
cos'è stani hoc a fuori dalla appena
famiglia weasley ciao a tutti i capelli
rossi ma che è lo sanno che mi piace di
capelli rossi solo che ci hanno 60 anni
l'una tranne questa il quartiere ti dà
il benvenuto sono nel quartiere della
topa che cos'è vai vai lorenzo vai mamma
mia cosa ho soprattutto a milano solo
neanche i vecchi sono del sud dove vai
oltre vari vince in certe vice sono
contentissimo di questo ciao grazie
grazie mille no tuttavia chi sei
no no non lo voglio no ai la barba se
infatti lasciato per terra ma lei messa
nella cassetta della posta anno c'era il
link se è una specie di torta regalo di
benvenuto
grazie grazie mille se avessi le bocce
sarebbe comunque grazie inviti
avvicinate entrate amici entrate
qualcuno di voi sa che cosa youtube
io faccio quello sono teso sono teso
perché sono una persona solitaria e
quindi vitro mi trovo male a
chiacchierare con la gente proprio
realistico sto gioco uguale voglio
giocarlo talmente seriamente che ho
messo i tratti
caratteriali precisi ai miei quindi
solitario che mi rende difficile il
parlare con la gente ma è vero quindi ho
fatto per l'area come se fossi io alle
fanno schifo
pochi abbiamo sbagliato approccio
ragazza scusami e le fanno schifo i
giochi e spero che la tutta la frutta ti
piaccia una ricetta di famiglia guarda
mi piace qualsiasi cosa perché qualsiasi
cosa che il cuscino faccio schifo quindi
ottimo però sarebbe bello mangiarla
vicini giusto per fare amicizia invece
mangiala lì avviene lei e propri
interessata anche se non le fanno scrive
videogiochi interessata proprio vuole
chiacchierare sa bene ciao zia come li
chiami saluta la nuova vicina al fisico
di una sessantenne ma la faccia di una
ventenne non si capisce max che boccia
vedere allora io parlerei di altro
quelli si stanno divertendo cena a due
di tipi come il successo stavolta
comunque ragazzi lorenzo insigne
romantico questi si sono solitamente a
fiore tanti hanno spesso bisogno di un
po di romanticismo
perché questo gioco rispetta esattamente
il mio essere amichevole per presente
con le persone infatti mi vedete
benissimo come sono presente io nelle
feste proprio mi diverto e sto con la
gente io so socializzare bene il
comitato di benvenuto è quasi finito tra
l'altro quindi
mi sa che se ne vanno tutti forse
dovremmo andare ti chiamo di nuovo il
benvenuto grazie ragazzi grazie mille
e stato molto bello avere degli amici
per una volta da due anni non è mai
entrato nessuno in casa mia il problema
è che io sono molto solitario ma sono
molto romantico come persona infatti mi
sono messo entrambe le cose
ed è una cosa un po discordante perché
per entrare in confidenza con una
persona ci metto una vita ma se mi
innamoro occhi per quella persone basta
quindi il problema è grave devo trovare
una persona che mi sopporti però vabbè
ci pensiamo dopo mobilio cose serie ma
lei da costruisci che lo utah questa
mobilio sì allora un po di soldi da
parte
dovrò lavorare comunque perché non mi
farò mai a mantenere per tutta la vita
fa sì che mi piace un po tutto su alcune
cose non mi piacciono però per il resto
non è male come casola prezzo di mano
dove sta il divano da de boni taleb
divano al divano con le mettiamo la
brancato re aggiornato non mi piace
troppo chic da questo molto carino
questo no scherzavo faccio schifo questo
è molto carino come divano questo è un
bel divano mi piace questo e poi le
serie mettiamo ecco questi che fanno
bandanti la solidarietà cos'è ok se
fosse stata la solitudine sarebbe stato
ancora meglio
guardate già come è cambiata è molto più
di prima
secondo me abbiamo tutte robe nuove
perfetto il mio stile c'è direi che
possiamo sono phil tutti i soldi ci
siamo ragazzi torniamo a vivere che
ma perché sono sempre a disagio io ma
che è ma perché 67 sul tablet ma si
molla l'onta basta poi a fare jogging se
ti prego ti prego sono flirt anteprima
che non ho una tipa finita è finita
della nuova e vitale in forma fisica
differenza di permettere agli eseguire
svariati allenamenti si prova non
ingrasso mai a prescindere se non s'ha
da fare ma cosa ti sei messo addosso
cos'è quella roba lì tra l'altro io
volendo con il tablet si possa accertare
bruciata federica sanna
voglio vederlo perché avere un certo
blenda da via prima neri molto carina
restiamo scelta ma cos'è arabo
socializzare adesso chattare sono
bravissimi bella la tv mi piace un sacco
e barbara d'urso chatta finché non vai a
dormire sole 10 ce la posso fare ragazzi
il giorno dopo penso che mi chiameranno
per lavorare credo non lo so immagino
perché sennò non avrebbe senso va a
dormire ma buono perfetto ma può
bellissima sta casa è bellissimo è
prestata una nave ma quanto voglio
vivere qua io no vi prego ditemi che
esiste una cosa del genere vi supplico
dove dove la trovo ma guarda ma dai
la nuova dava bellissimo bellissimo
voglio una casa del già in parte lo smau
che l'avevano un'auto rischio però lo sa
o che cosa incredibile sveglia di sole 8
del mattino
ok sono ispiri sono svegliati ispirato
lorenzo singh creativo tra un ospite
spesso l'ispirazione ma sarà l'attività
creativa vengono ignorate ne soffrono
dal punto di vista emotivo va bene ma
sono identico si vabbè mi sono scelto
identico file a patto che poi andiamo a
capire dove lavoriamo cerca un lavoro ma
il tasto cerca un lavoro che allora
perfetto agente segreto vivi senza farti
notare come genti incognito il criminale
solo 9 dollari all'ora pochissimo il
cuoco freelance mestieri disponibili
artista programmatore scrittore ok
artista digitale sarebbe tipo youtube
influenza di siri 18 dollari al si
volevano allora ma dai che figata
va bene mi faccio l'influenza dai dai
massi massimo
sì ma chi se ne frega vacanze i primi
tre giorni vado a fare l'influente il
recensore imbrattacarte intervista dei
simboli dove intervistare they seem per
lavoro che allora va bene questo lavoro
mi piace un sacco e devo fare
l'influenza riporre faranno influenza
influenziamo l'agenda io non ho capito
ma il lavoro da influencer dove che va
in ufficio dell'influenza cosa però la
porta c'è chiara ferragni cos'è che
succede dove doveva dove che lavora
un'influenza non so tra l'altro vediamo
nel mentre ne approfitto per vedere chi
ci è vicino a casa mia tesi sono
richieste a casa qua trasferisci unita
fondata in una galleria mafia vita
familiare non lo so io posso creare
altre unità familiare lo sapete che vi
dico io adesso mi creo come vicini the
fair e sabrina va bene nel prossimo
episodio vedrete step fair e che vivono
in questa cosa qua perché più grande c'è
bisogno di in due
sabrina e sasha vivono qua e poi mi
metto anche some così faccio tutte le
famiglie di youtube che mi vivono di
fianco sarà fantastico ragazzi abbiamo
iniziato una nuova avventura sulle stime
sono molto contento è perché questa è la
porterò molto avanti visto che io sto
facendo seriamente con i miei tratti
caratteriali tutto come se fossi io
nella veri nella realtà quindi è tutto
veramente reale il che è veramente figo
la prima volta che lo prendo così
seriamente sì come al solito ragazzi se
vi è piaciuto questo momento mi piace
anche a ministro cioè comitato ad e
schizzare e noi come sempre ci vediamo
al prossimo visto dai ragazzi
[Musica]